- Today I'm talking about CVs,
but not any CVs, I'm
talking about your CVs.
I'm reviewing your CVs.
CVs that you sent me before the session.
I reviewed them thoroughly
and I will give you my tips
and pointers on how you can improve them
if you're looking to apply
for a high profile job
such as a consulting
firm or investment bank.
Welcome to another coffee
bank with me, my name
is Heinrich, and this is
my channel Firm Learning
where I try to help you
to become successful
in the first years of your career.
To start off your career
right you need to get
the job in the first place,
and a part of getting the job
is getting your
application material right,
and this is specifically your
cover letter and your CV.
And today we're going to
especially focus on the CVs
of your application material.
And to make this as hands
on as possible I offered
on my Instagram that you
could send me your CVs
and that I would review
them and give you my tips
here on my YouTube channel
on how I would change
and edit them to improve them,
to make them even stronger.
As always, if you're taking
any value out of this video
at all, please hit the
like button for the YouTube
algorithm, and also
subscribe to my channel
to stay up to date and all my content.
I'm releasing at least
one video every Saturday
here on this YouTube channel.
And if you want to see
even more content from me
also follow me on my Instagram,
my handle is Firm Learning
to stay up to date, and
potentially also participating
in similar videos like this
by getting your material
reviewed in future videos as well.
Today we are going to
proceed in the following way;
first I'm giving you some general remarks
on how the structure of
your CV, in my opinion,
should look like, and
then I picked four CVs
of the CVs that you sent me,
and we will go in depth into
lots of detail in these CVs,
and I'm going to make
several observations,
things that I observed, what
you can do to improve them,
and I believe these are really interesting
and helpful insights
for all of you as well,
things that you should all take care of,
things that you should look out for
when you create your
CVs, and many of these
are things that I see
frequently done wrong
by many people, so I hope and trust
that this is really going to be valuable
and interesting to all of you.
And to start it off it is
important for me to say
that all the remarks and
the things that I will say,
and critique, and give you as a feedback,
these are my opinions.
I do not claim that I know
the truth about how a perfect
CV looks like, there are
many opinions on that,
and maybe if you ask other people
they will give you another opinion.
But hey, you asked me, this is my channel,
so my opinion is what you will get.
And as always, take it
with a grain of salt,
and in the end it's important
that you are comfortable
with your application material,
and if you have a good reason to deviate
from what I'm telling
you, then of course do so.
So let's go briefly into
some general remarks
about the CV structure.
One thing that I would
strongly recommend to you
is to have a one-pager format.
The one-pager CV is just
so much easier to read
and comprehend than a two-pager CV.
Especially in Anglo-Saxon
countries, one-pager CVs
are the standard, they are the norm,
and there you really should apply
with a one-pager CV.
In some countries, such
as Germany, two-pager CVs
are generally accepted as
well, but as a general rule
you should never go over two pages,
and in general, I highly encourage you,
even in Germany, to go for the one-pager,
it is always much better,
I love it when I get
a one-pager CV on my desk.
In my humble opinion it just
looks much more professional,
and it's much easier for
you to communicate yourself
on the one-pager format.
And from the CVs that
you sent me some are on
a two-pager format, and on these examples
I will try to give you some
hints on what you can cut
down to get it down to a one-pager.
Now let's look into the content blocks,
what are the key content
blocks that your CV
should consist of, and in the structure
that I will propose here,
there are three main
content blocks and then
two minor content blocks
in the footer.
And I prepared a very basic
template of these different
content blocks that you have,
just as a rough guideline.
At the very top you should
have your personal information,
your contact information,
so state your name,
your address, your email,
your telephone number,
and so on, this'll make it
easy for the company to contact
you without needing to look up other
application material of yours.
Then the three main
content blocks are first
your professional experience,
second your education,
and third your extracurriculars.
So in your professional
experience this is where you list
all your jobs, internships,
and similar things.
In your education you list
all the degrees that you have,
the universities that you attended.
In the extracurriculars
you especially list
all the social things
that you did, so any kind
of volunteering that you
did, nonprofit organizations
where you had some kind of
leadership positions in,
and similar things like that.
Then you have honors and awards
section where you can list
all your academic achievements,
prizes, scholarships,
dean list positions, and
anything similar like that
that will make you stand out.
And in the end you have an
other qualifications section
where you can list all
your language skills,
IT skills, any other
certificates that you get,
and similar things that
you might want to highlight
to your potential future employer.
So of course this is
just a rough structure,
and you can debate how exactly
the wording of these headers
should be, you can debate
whether you should add
an additional line for
hobbies at the very bottom,
but generally speaking
if you follow a structure
like that then your overall
structure should be fine.
And now when reviewing the
individual CVs I will often
refer back to this structure,
so have this in mind,
this is the basic recommended structure
that I will refer to.
So without further ado,
let's jump into it,
let's get practical and
review the first CV.
And the first thing I'd like to address
is the one-pager format.
So as you can easily see
this CV is on a two-pager
format, and I just wanna address the point
that many of you are saying,
"Well I just cannot fit this
on a one-pager."
But I'm telling you,
you can absolutely fit
such a CV on a one-pager format.
So let's just go over couple of things
this guy could do to
get it on a one-pager.
And the first is the header of the CV,
with all the contact information.
Here just so much space
is wasted on a header,
all the information here
could just easily be
included in two lines or so,
and we will see other CVs
in this set of four CV
where this has been done.
So for your header don't
put each individual
item of information in one new line,
but have them all in one
line after each other,
and this is absolutely fine.
Next is the borders at the sides.
He has a significant margin to the left
and to the right, and if
you will just take out
a bit of the margin he
probably wouldn't need
some of the text breaks, and
some of the bullet points,
so you would save a
whole line by doing that.
Same is true for the
spacing between the dates
and the text, there's just so much space
between the date and the
text, if you would just let
the text start a bit more to
the left you would save space
and probably save several
lines in the indentation.
Before we now dive into
the content let's go over
some other minor format and layout things
which I would recommend to improve.
So first regarding the date range,
whenever you write something that is still
an ongoing activity, the way he puts it
with a dash and then nothing after that
is a bit weird, I would
probably not do it like this.
Instead I would just write
"since" and then the date,
without this empty dash afterwards.
Then the font that he is using
looks a bit informal to me,
so I'm not exactly sure
which font that is,
probably something similar
to Calibri, but at least
for my taste it looks a bit
too playful and informal,
so I'd probably go for another one.
And just a little minor
thing on the bottom right
you see that he still wrote
(speaking foreign language),
so this is German for page,
so of course if you have
different versions of your
CVs in different languages
please make sure that you
translate every single word.
This is just a small
inaccuracy that of course
should be avoided.
Now let's dive into the content
and let's start with
the education section.
What you see here that
this guy did some kind
of a computer science degree,
and probably especially if
you're fresh out of
university with your degree
I'd also try to highlight
your area of specialization,
all of the focus fields that
you did during your studies,
and of course if you
apply for a specific job
I'd try to tailor it a
bit that it really fits
the content of the job.
So for instance, if you
apply for a finance position
try to tailor what you write here,
your areas of specialization
towards that role,
highlight the finance
courses that you did.
And regarding grades, yes
it's correct you should always
put your grades on the CV.
Two tips that I would
have to maybe improve
the appearance of your
grade is that first,
whenever it makes sense for
you to name the percentile
of your grade, do it.
So here on this grade, 2.18
is of course an okayish grade,
but maybe you're studying in
a very tough degree subject,
maybe he's already in the top
10% or top 15% of performers
of his class with that grade.
So I do not know how in computer science
the grade distribution looks
like, but if you can make
such a claim, that you are
in the top 10% of your class
it's of course highly beneficial,
and then I would really
recommend you to add that
to your grade section.
Another advice is with your thesis,
so with your bachelor
thesis or master thesis,
if you have achieved
a grade in your thesis
that is significantly
better than the overall
GPA of your degree,
then I would add the GPA
of the thesis as well in
brackets after the normal grade.
Regarding the exchange
semester that this guy did,
I believe it takes far too much space,
especially in comparison
to the main degrees
that he's actually doing.
So for the exchange
semester I'd put all of this
only one line, by this you save one line
and could potentially invest
it in going into more detail
on what you did in your main degree.
Now to the work experience section,
and here I would encourage
you to whenever possible
use parallel grammar structures.
And what this means is that
from a grammar point of view
you start all your
bullets in the same way.
And you see this nicely
done at his Suzuki entry
where he started both of
the bullets with a verb,
and usually for the
work experience section
it's good and advised to
start with such a verb,
because this now emphasizes
more on what you did,
what you actually did at these positions,
and this is always what you want.
If you have bullets which are all written
in the parallel grammar structure,
it's just much easier to understand,
much more effortless to read,
it just gives an overall
much more professional appearance.
Now the next thing on the work experience,
and this might be the
most important point,
because this is a feedback
point that I will need to give
to every single CV.
In the bullets describing
your work experience,
you should focus on the
impact, you should focus
on what you have achieved,
and not only as a team
but what your contribution
to a specific point was.
What I mean by that is
that you should not just
write a couple of general
buzz words describing
the activities on a
superficial level such as
first level support, but
you should rather say
exactly and specifically what you did
and what your impact was,
and whenever possible
also to quantify that.
So just a little example,
instead of writing
"first level support", you
can write something like
"Responsible for first level support
"of thousand employees, comma,
resolving 50 plus tickets everyday."
Now this sounds much more like impact,
if I read it as somebody who gets the CV
I can imagine much more
what you actually did
than just by reading first level support,
because this can mean
everything and nothing.
Another example here for the PwC position,
if you talk about a role
out of a monitoring tool,
try to give a bit more detail,
what exactly did you do and
how can you quantify that?
So for instance, say how many
users actually used your tool.
So if you can claim that
you as a working student
created a tool that afterwards
hundreds of consultants
used at PWC, of course that
is extremely impressive.
So add a bit more flavor,
or say specifically
what you did, what your contribution was,
what the impact was that you delivered,
and also make it quantified.
This is really what
distinguishes a strong framing
of work experience from a weak one.
The next point of observation that I have,
but I also see other people doing wrong,
is that you do not need
to give equal weight,
equal space in your CV
to every single individual position.
So in this specific example the position
that you had as a student assistant,
at the Hessisches
Landesmuseum, probably is a bit
less relevant, it's a bit less impressive
for the most jobs that you will apply to,
compared to for instance
your PwC position.
So I'd already give more space in your CV
to the things that are really important
and relevant, and less space to the things
that are less relevant.
And at some point if you've
collected now even more
internships, maybe even
already have a job,
at some point you can also start dropping
these less important
positions that you have.
You do not need to list
every single internship
that you did during your studies.
And just as example also, for me on my CV,
even though I did all kinds of internship
during my university times,
most of them I just do not
list anymore on my CV
because now of course
I like to emphasize far more
the actual full-time work
experience that I got after graduating.
Now regarding the qualifications
and skills sections,
the first suggestion that
I would have is to put
this behind, below the
volunteering section.
So as I've shown you
in my overall template
I believe it's common
practice to rather start
with your extracurriculars,
with your volunteering,
and then start with the
qualifications and skills.
Now here if I look into the
qualifications and skills here
I believe there's lots of
opportunities to cut down
space as well.
So for the language there's just no need
to put languages in individual lines,
you can just write them
in one line, one language
after each other.
So languages, and then German,
English, Russian, French,
with the proficiency level in brackets
is completely fine, it will
just take you one line.
And then next regarding
software and tools,
and I know many people do
that, but from my perspective
there's no need at all to write about
your Microsoft Office skills.
If you're a master
graduate from a university
people will just assume that
you have basic office skills,
exception might be if
you have really in depth
knowledge on specific
fields, for instance VBA,
then yes you can put
this, but just writing
about Microsoft Office in
general is not something
I would do, it's just a waste of space.
And the very same is true for Windows.
I mean, come on, people will just know,
expect you, and trust
you that you will have
basic knowledge of Windows,
there's no need of writing that.
And here there is a distinction between
software and the programming,
frankly here I also believe
that this is just a waste of space,
you can consolidate this much more.
So for instance, yeah I'm not an expert
but at least based on, I
know Anaconda and Spyder
are IDEs for Python, so
it's completely sufficient
to just say that you are
proficient in Python.
There's no need now to
also mention all the IDEs
that you have worked with in the past.
Maybe this might be a bit more different
if you really apply
for a computer science,
for a software developer position
and you know that these are the things
that are going to be used there,
but for a general business
position there's no need into
going this much of detail.
Same is true for R and R Studio,
you do not need to mention
that you're proficient
in R Studio if you're proficient in R,
I mean this is pretty
much self explanatory.
So bottom line here
again from my perspective
you can consolidate this whole section
in just one line under
the title of IT skills,
or something like that, and
then just list all of these
things, then you should be completely.
Now regarding the volunteering
section, and here would focus
much more on impact, on your leadership,
and focusing on mentioning
as many things as possible.
What people will look for,
if they read these CVs
is not that you have been
part of as many social
organizations as possible,
where maybe you supported
an event or did some minor activities,
similar to the work experience
what you should really
highlight and focus on here is the impact
that you had.
It's your leadership
in such an organization
that will make you really stand out.
So I'd say it's completely okay to mention
three positions under
extracurriculars, I believe it's also
completely fine to only mention two,
but then focus much more
on mentioning the specific
things that you did.
And again, quantify, so if
you organized the conference,
say how many people
attended the conference,
if you organized a
fundraiser, say what amount
of funds you raised.
If you're the head of some
kind of social organization,
say how many people you
are responsible for,
how many members this organization has.
This is what's impressive,
this is how you show
your leadership skills,
and volunteering in the end
should be about the impact that you had,
so make sure that you mention this impact
as precisely as possible.
Now to the achievements
section here again I believe
you can put this much more concisely.
In general I do not believe
that it is necessary
to put the dates for
scholarships that you have.
Nobody will care when exactly
you had a scholarship,
of course if you then
submit all the supporting
documents with your application
then you should also
have references for all your scholarships,
and then these details
will be listed there
if anybody's interested.
But in general nobody
will care about that.
So no need to put the
dates, and instead of that,
again, I would just have one
line with your scholarships
and then just list all the scholarships
that you have collected.
This is hugely much more effective,
and you can save lots of space for that.
And similar things too,
for the publications,
so in general if you have
a background in academia,
maybe you did a PhD and have
all kinds of publications,
then what you can do is
make an appendix to your CV
listing all the publications.
So what you can do here,
instead of now listing
the full citation of your paper, is again
in the achievements
section to have one remark,
just briefly mention that
you have a publication,
the XYZ Journal, and then if
the journal is well rated,
so if the journal has I'd
say at least a B rating,
or an A rating, or ideally
of course an A plus rating,
then rather say how the journal is rated
because this is what's really impressive,
in the end it's not
impressive to have a journal
publication in a
completely unknown journal,
but it is of course extremely
impressive if you have
an A plus publication.
So rather talk about this
than spending all this space
on giving the full citation
of your journal paper,
somebody is really interested in that
he can look it up anyways.
Okay, first one done, let's
jump into the next CV.
And I'll try not to not
repeat myself too much,
so I will not stress every single point
in the same way that I now I already did.
But of course if you hear or see something
that I already gave feedback
on in the earlier CVs
the feedback will be
applicable here as well.
And this lady provided me some questions
that she asked me on her CV,
so I will now go over these questions
and answer them, and by that I hope touch
all the relevant points here.
And the first question is
whether she should keep
the one-pager CV because
she feels like the CV
is far too full, more
than enough stuff going on
to spread it out into two pages.
And by now I hope the
answer is no surprise
to you that no, you should
keep the one-pager format,
this at least would be
my strong recommendation.
And I have no doubt at
all that you can fit
all this information
easily on a one-pager CV.
Because now the second
question was what I think
about her layout, what you
directly see of course,
this is a bit of an unorthodox layout.
This is not the classical investment style
one-pager CV that you see out there.
And my general advice here
would be to be careful
with these kind of things.
So while of course I wouldn't
say that it looks bad
or something like that, you
should very carefully look out
for the types of jobs that you apply for.
Especially if you apply for consulting
or for investment banking,
these companies are a bit
conservative, and having
such an alternative design
approach for your CV will
at least not help you
in the process.
So I'm pretty sure that
nobody in the HR department
of Goldman Sachs, BCG or McKinsey
or wherever, will say,
"Wow, this layout looks so great,"
this is just not how it works.
So best case, people
will be just indifferent,
but of course worst
case will be that people
are actually irritated by that.
Now what could go through the head
of an HR person is that this
candidate potentially just
didn't do her research.
This candidate just doesn't
know how a CV should look like
in such a professional environment.
And this of course is not
the reaction that you want
when you apply to these firms.
So where I might see this a
bit differently is if you apply
for a creative position.
If you apply for a marketing
agency, or any other job
where creativity and
open mindedness is really
at the core of the job description.
So for these kinds of
positions, yes, I believe
it might be a great idea
to be a bit more creative,
to think a bit more out
of the box regarding
the layout and the style of your CV,
but of course this is
now a very specific field
that we are looking at.
So my overall opinion on
that is that there isn't much
of a upside of using
these kind of alternative
CV formats, but there is
the downside that somebody
significantly dislikes this
and believes it's unprofessional.
So I would just recommend not doing that
and rather going for a standard CV format.
You want to impress by
the content of your CV
and not by the layout.
Another thing I dislike about the layout
that optically the focus of
this is here on the left part,
there's the highlight.
So I would claim that this left section
is rather the stuff that
you usually would put
in the footer of your
CV, so it's not actually
the stuff that is really at
the core of what the viewer
should be interested in.
But the most important stuff
is rather on the right.
So I do not think that
you're doing yourself a favor
by setting it up this way,
by highlighting the things
that are less important for the viewer.
Another thing that I'm
noticing, at least if I see it
correctly, is that the
font size on the right
is smaller than the font size on the left.
And to me this just doesn't
make sense for the one reason
again that the stuff on
the right is actually
more important than the stuff on the left,
but also I believe that
it's in general bad practice
to use different font sizes in your CV.
The only exception might be
maybe the name and the header
which you maybe can do in a
bit of a higher font size,
but even this is not
necessary, and for sure within
the body of your CV you
shouldn't work with different
font sizes, this is just
confusing to the eye.
And another general remark
for your date ranges,
make sure that the orders of your elements
follows a logic.
And usually you start by the
things that are still ongoing,
then you order the other
elements anti-chronologically
when they have been completed,
or when this episode
has been finished.
But this is now not the case here,
because if it is the case that the things
that are still ongoing are
put first, then why is this
element this going on since November 16
there at the bottom?
Why isn't it above the TEDx element
if it's still ongoing?
So the order of the elements
here just doesn't make sense
to me, make sure that yours do.
And some other questions
that this lady had
is first what can I take out?
And second what do I do with
all these online courses
that I took?
So let's start with these online courses,
let's start with your education section.
Because I agree that the
way that this education
section is setup at the
moment is pretty confusing.
There's just so many elements in there,
and you really need to pay
close attention til you really
understand what your actual degrees are
and what some other study activities were,
for instance these online
courses that you did in parallel.
My general advice here
would be that I wouldn't put
online courses at the same
level as your full university
degrees, rather have this
footer section of your CV,
this other qualifications
section, and there you can then
list all your online courses,
and you shouldn't have
more than one line for each online course
that you took.
This will save you
significant space here above,
and also will make it much
easier to read and much easier
to process what exactly
you did, what exactly
your main education and background is,
because of course at least
today how HR departments
see that, this still your
university education,
and less some online
courses that you took.
And similar thing holds
true for this project study
from 16, so if I understand
this correctly this lady
took some university level
courses while she was
still in high school, while
this is of course pretty cool
I'd also not highlight this
here in the education section.
I'd probably rather frame it
for something to be included
in an honors and awards section.
You can frame it as an academic honor
that even though you
were only in high school
the university already accepted you
for a university level course.
So I'd probably write something like this,
"Admitted to the XYZ
Project," and then briefly
describing it afterwards.
And by doing that you can
really save some space
here on the main section of your CV
where you should really
highlight the main stages
of your academic career.
The next question was
how she should handle
her scholarships section,
what scholarships to include
and how to put it on the CV.
And again if you follow my basic template
then you have section honors and awards,
and this is the section
where you can place
all your scholarships.
And now to what scholarship
exactly you should include,
well something like the
Fulbright, of course,
is a very prestigious and
well known scholarship,
so yes this for sure is something
that you should include.
Now something like the
FemTec here, I do not know
what exactly this is,
but sounds good, why not?
I mean, sure, sure you can include this.
Now to one thing where there
are many questions around
is this e-fellows scholarship.
So this is a scholarship that is pretty
well spread in Germany,
it's something that quite
a lot of people have, but
of course not everybody has,
so people ask themselves,
well should I include
my e-fellows scholarship or not?
And my simple answer would
be that probably I would
include it if I have
nothing better to show.
So again, looking at Germany,
once you have collected
a BMBF scholarship, something like
(speaking foreign language),
or something like that,
then for sure I wouldn't
mention it anymore,
but if your section on honors and awards
still looks a bit empty
then yes, sure, why not?
Then just include it.
And this is now a general
point that I also said earlier,
what exactly you will
include or not include
on your CV depends on
what stage of your career,
what stage also of your university
study program you're at.
In the beginning if you're
fresh out of high school,
if you are in the first
semesters of your university
program, then it's completely
okay to also include
for instance internships that you did
during your high school
time, which maybe were only
a couple of weeks long, but
over time, once you did more
relevant internships, more
prestigious internships,
then at some point take
this older stuff out.
In my opinion you are
strongly devaluing your strong
internships if they stand next to this
high school thing you did for two weeks,
some where where you were
a really young person.
And same thing is true
here for the scholarships,
I would leave it in until I
have enough other academic
honors and awards that then at some point
can replace this e-fellows scholarship.
Now regarding the
content, how you describe
your work experience,
this is really an area
of your CV where I would
highly recommend you to go
over that again.
Now I do not want to
repeat all things I said
for the previous CV, but
it's really important
that you focus much more
on your contribution,
on the impact that you had while working
in these positions.
And again, quantify, always quantify,
try to have a number in almost
every single bullet point
that you use when describing
your work experience,
and similar thing, actually,
is true for your volunteering,
for your extracurricular
experience as well.
And now to your volunteering
section, here you list
five different activities,
most of them also overlap.
As somebody who reads the
CV I would probably doubt
that you were really able
to have a significant impact
in all these positions, so what
I would really recommend you
is to focus more, maybe instead
of mentioning five things,
rather cut it down to
the three or so things
that you really feel like
were the most important,
most relevant to you.
And here again now focus
on your leadership,
on your impact, what you did
to really make a contribution,
make an impact to your community.
This is what your extracurricular section
should be all about, how
you made a contribution
for the good of society.
Now to the next CV.
What I want to point
out in the beginning is
that without reading a single
word, just from the look
and feel of that, this is how a classical
Anglo-Saxon one-pager CV looks like.
So if you wonder what a
good and sorted layout
of an MBB consulting, of
an investment banking CV
looks like, this is the look
and feel that you wanna go for.
Maybe some of you believe
that it's too full,
that it's too packed with content,
but what you need to
understand is that the feeling
that you wanna create, the look and feel,
needs to be that it's completely packed
with amazingness of yourself.
This is the picture
that you wanna portray.
So somebody who reads the
CV, you wanna just go over it
and read every single
line, and every single line
is just impressive,
great university names,
great grades, great accomplishments,
great impact, great
numbers, this is the feeling
that you wanna go for.
What you also see here is that in contrast
to all the other CVs he
has very little margins
at the side, at the
top, and at the bottom.
Again, this is very typical
for these kinds of CVs,
'cause this really
allows you to just stuff
lots of content into them.
This guy is currently
an LSE master student
and he told me that he already worked with
the career services at LSE on his CV,
and you can really see that.
At least for these high profile consulting
and banking jobs, this is the style
that you should go for.
Another thing that I'd
also like to point out
is how little space he
is using in the header
to put all his contact information.
If you look at the other CVs,
there the contact information
take a quarter, or even
a third of the page.
This is just a complete waste of space.
You can just have that in two
lines or so in the header,
and this is completely fine.
So even though this is
already looking great,
I do believe there are a couple of things
he can do to make this even stronger.
One thing is that at least in my opinion
he did a bit too much on the formatting.
So he uses capitalization, he uses bold,
he uses italic, he uses underlines.
Individually this is
okay but I wouldn't do
all these things at the same time.
So probably for instance
here I wouldn't work also
with italic font.
If almost everything in
your CV is highlighted
by capitalization,
boldness, italic, underlines
and so on, this loses meaning,
and these kind of highlights
you want to use to create a structure
on your CV, so I'd probably
just take one step back
and probably take out for
instance the italic font.
The next thing is that
even though, as I said,
it's great to really pack
it with lots of content,
you should make sure that
it's easy to understand
when the new entries starts.
Here I believe that the
distance between two entries
is almost the same as the
distance between two lines
within one entry.
So I would change that and
I would slightly increase
the distance between two
entries to make it easier
to read when a new entry begins.
And yes, this is taking some space,
but in a few moments I will
also give you a bit more
suggestions on what you can
do to save some more space.
So let's now jump into
the education section.
The first remark that I wanna make here
is how you state foreign grades.
So this is now a CV in English,
but he studied in Germany
in his undergraduate.
And then what some people
do, as in this example,
is that they take their
German grade and then they try
to calculate that into
some other kind of format,
and here this example onto
the American format of 4.0.
And here the general rule
is that you should not
tamper with your grades.
You shouldn't by your
own initiative now try
to apply some kind of calculation formula
to transfer it in any kind
of other grade system.
You should always state the
grade exactly in the way
that it is stated in your
diploma that you received.
So of course now if you did
receive a diploma in English
and it showed the grade
in exactly this way,
then it is fine, but in
general I would not do
these kind of calculations by yourself.
Same true is here for this
German School of Milan
for the 98 out of 100 scale.
So of course if you received
a diploma where the grade
is stated this way, then
I would put it this way,
but I wouldn't do these kind
of calculations by yourself.
Now just a minor remark on
the bullet with the poli sci
program here, there seems
to be a double spacing,
so just take out one of the spaces.
Regarding this Brown
University pre-college program,
this is likely something
where you can save a bit
more space, I would probably
not put this as prominently
here in your main education section,
but for me this is rather
something you can put below
under other qualifications.
And the reason is that even
though Brown University
of course sounds great, it's
a great Ivy League university,
you usually do not get admitted
to these kind of summer
school programs due to
your academic merit,
but usually you just pay for
it, and everybody knows that,
so I wouldn't consider
this now a great academic
achievement, but rather put it below under
other qualifications where
you can just state it
in one line or so and thereby save space.
Now regarding the content
here again, I just wanna
encourage you to focus much
more on your contribution,
on your impact.
Just as an example in
your childcare position
you write that you
developed teaching plans
and that you taught children.
Here I would really quantify this now,
for instance by saying that
you taught 200 students
in total, or by saying
that you taught three
different classes of students,
or anything like that.
This just makes it much more tangible
and really shows that
you made this impact,
that you were the teacher.
Really always stress much
more on your contribution,
the impact that you had.
And on the next point,
the fundraiser point,
the guy asked me whether he should include
now the quantification of
$1,000, because he feels
like maybe this is a
bit little of an amount
to mention that.
And at least in my opinion,
again, even though it's not
the largest amount, I believe
it's much more honest,
it's much more tangible to
write that you raised $1,000
than to not writing that.
Personally believe that
this is the better thing
to do, and that this is the thing
that is just more powerful.
Hi guys, Heinrich here.
So while editing I noticed that somehow
a part of the video was missing.
And now the next session
refers to a question
this guy asked me, and
he asked me two questions
specifically, first how
important is it really
to quantify all your achievements?
And second, is it okay
to exaggerate in your CV?
To what extent can you maybe inflate a bit
the things that you did,
and what is the line
that you should not cross?
So now the next section refers to.
Yes, quantification is great,
it just helps you to make
the things that you did
sound much more tangible
and really helps to tear out the impact
that you had in your roles.
So to what level is it okay to exaggerate?
And here I'd make the remark that yes,
it's true, that probably
most of the CVs that you get
in your hand, there's some
level of exaggeration in it,
of course people try to portray themselves
as positively as possible,
so because your competition
is doing you should of course not be shy.
Make sure that you at least
state all the achievements
in the appropriate level of greatness.
Do not hold back, really make it salient
what the impact is that you had,
what the leadership is that you showed,
do not be modest here in your CV,
this is not what will help you.
But of course there is
a limit, and this limit
is where you're now making
factually wrong statements.
This for me is now an ethics issue.
While I'm sure that many,
many people exaggerate
the things that they write on their CV,
even beyond what's
actually factually true,
in my opinion this is just unethical
and I just would not cross this line.
This will probably put you
at a slight disadvantage
compared to some other
candidates, but hey,
life is unfair.
So now last but not least, CV number four.
This is now again a two page CV,
and here again I would
of course recommend you
to put it on one page, especially
because the second page
is barely used.
So here it would be especially
easy for you to consolidate
it all on one page,
and this is something that therefore
I would highly recommend.
Next thing you notice is
that the header is missing
with the contact information, so I assume
he just took it out to anonymize himself,
but of course in your
actual CV you should include
a contact information section at the top.
One thing that I like about this CV
is how he put the dates, saying
this because I now referred
to this earlier how he's using
these numbers for the months,
and then the slash and then the year,
I believe this is a very
clean and easy to read
and easy to understand format.
So at least for my taste,
this works quite well.
Regarding the overall
layout, be a bit careful
that everything is nicely aligned.
So what you can see here
is that these blue lines
they do not neatly start at
the very left of the letters,
but rather a bit more to
the right, so this looks
a bit unclean, this is
just not correctly aligned,
so just have a look at that again, please.
And the same is for the
indentation, so at least
if I see this correctly,
at the left, the dates,
they do not all begin
at the very same plane,
so make sure that the
indentation is consistent
and all the bullets
start at the same level.
So what this guy did
very well is the GMAT.
So usually I would recommend
to not put the GMAT
above at the education
section, but maybe below
in the honors, or maybe in
the other qualifications
section, or somewhere below, but of course
if you did a very strong
GMAT as this gentleman did,
maybe especially then if
your other grades aren't
that strong, then it is an
option that you could go for
to then also include the
GMAT next to the degree
that you took the GMAT for.
Here of course the GMAT
of 740 is a very strong
score that might very well overcompensate
some other weaknesses in the
GPAs of the other degrees.
Now because already I said
so much about how you should
write your bullets in your
work experience section,
let's rather look into the skills section
because here he did something which I see
many people do in some variations,
which at least personally I believe
that you should not do this.
And this is this weird
scale that he is using
to measure the level of his skills.
And while first of all I
find it highly doubtful
whether you should
include Microsoft Office
skills in general on your
CV as I also said earlier,
but let's now assume that you include it,
where I would now be very, very careful
is if you put yourself as a full expert
on such a topic, six out of six points,
so basically 100% proficient
user of this tool,
and just to contrast
that, so I would consider
myself a pretty proficient
user with for instance Excel
as well, but I would
never claim that I'm at
the 100%, that I know it all about a tool
such as Excel.
Because in Excel, even though
you're already quite advanced,
there are always more topics to learn,
more topics to master, let's
start with array formulas,
with PowerPivot, with VBA,
all these very advanced
techniques, and if you really
master all these things,
if you're really an expert, then okay,
then maybe at some point
you can write that.
But just be careful here,
because as an interviewer,
if I see this, I would
just directly pick it up
and challenge the candidate a bit on that.
And then also the Microsoft
Office suite is so vast
besides these basic programs
like PowerPoint, Excel,
or Word, it also includes
programs like SharePoint,
or Access, and do you really
master all these tools
at the 100% level?
So guys, be careful.
And similar things are true
for your language skills.
So if you put languages on
your CV on the B1 level or so,
then be ready that the
interviewer maybe in the middle
of the interview switches to
Italian, or switches to French,
just to test the bit
whether you do have these
basic language skills
that you claim to have.
So if you can speak these
languages at these levels,
this is perfect, but
this is just something
where it's really easy to call you out
in an interview, so be careful.
And the last thing I wanna
draw your attention to here
on the activities section is hunting.
And with hunting, it's a bit
similar to an affiliation
to a political party, so
while I trust that it can be
a very comforting leisure
activity, maybe also
a great conversation starter,
if your interview partner
is interested in that, or
maybe does the same activity,
there just are people who
see things like hunting
very critically, and some
of them are not really open
for arguments, but rather see these things
on an ideological level.
So I would probably not write on my CV
that I am a hunter, because
there might be some people
in HR believing that
hunters are really evil
and unmoral persons, and
by now I trust it's easy
to make an argument in
the exact other direction,
you just do not wanna put
your application at risk
for such a stupid little thing.
Okay, so let's wrap it
up, this was my review
of your CVs, I hope that
you found this interesting
and valuable, and I hope that
you really took something
out for your individual CVs as well,
that this really helped
you to get your application
material to the next level.
So now I'd love to hear also from you,
what you have, other suggestions,
other tips for the four
CVs that we looked at.
Leave a comment below
in the comment section
so that also the other
people here in the community
can participate from your knowledge,
I would highly appreciate that.
And as always, if you took
any value out of this video
at all, please hit the
like button for the YouTube
algorithm, and also
subscribe to my channel
to stay up to date on my content.
And please also turn on
the notification bell
as otherwise YouTube might not show you
my videos, even if you're
already subscribed to me.
If you wanna see even
more content from me,
also follow me on my Instagram,
my handle is FirmLearning.
Thanks for watching, my name is Heinrich,
this is Firm Learning, have
a good day to all of you.